[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
whoa come back to the break room our
daily keeps you updated on all the nerdy
news you need to know about coming up
today we're going to be talking about
James Gunn debunking rumors oh he's
tired of it
there you go Avatar three is gonna be a
fire in
what not water I guess Last of Us season
two possibilities and with us to do so
we got Eric Owusu hi internet happy New
Year are we still saying that yeah
when did they stop saying it oh February
3rd oh
saying happy Black History Month yes I'm
still writing if you find this note I'm
dead on all my checks all right oh my
God if you're reading this it's too late
yeah that was Tommy Bechtel and by the
way there'll be no mandatory fun today
we don't have time we have too much to
talk about I don't want anyone adding me
no you don't have to ask me in Twitter
what happened to mandatory fund it's not
canceled mandatory fun will never die
mandatory fun is the friends we had
along the way yeah well put well put and
then we have Brandon Barrick I'm still
writing on all my checks I gave you all
the clues Mr policeman wait a second is
Brandon my murderer did we just solve
this
up in here
he's been writing his Shadows
[Laughter]
so dumb
[Laughter]
today thank goodness where are you
redeemable but but we do have some
headlines oh baby
I'm so depressed
every time
they interrupt just three times she
shuts down emotionally you're also both
wearing the lovely uh Halloween cards
this is great mine is peach like my ass
oh my God
that answer is that I was wondering a
new image of Vin Diesel in the upcoming
fast X fast end uh was just released
here it is uh love the difference
shocking imagery from the set I do I
like the flex of like uh his neck
because it's ten times bigger than the
first one yeah I think he came back
uh like putting your last name on your
shirt yeah I think I feel like most
service jobs you put they usually put
the first thing because it's unsettling
if you're on a job and someone calls you
by your last name well I think because
they're friends they call him by his
last name yeah I guess Dominic or Dom
okay I noticed white men love to call
each other by their last names is that
just a white man thing that's a military
thing too yeah it is well where I used
to work every man's that you never
called me by the first name it'd always
be Kearns like Smith Johnson it was
never about anything about David
currents yeah
shout out David Kearns wait I I have I I
have something about the same should you
put that image back up see okay so John
I don't want to call you out this
actually isn't the full image John is
showing an edited image he's actually
standing over the mutilated corpse of
Dwayne Johnson
that's the full image he's in the
blackout he said hierarchy these nuts
what's that what does that image smell
like to you family family what does
family smell like too yeah I think it
starts like it depends on the family he
looks like he's about to blow chunks
yeah it smells like Malibu Rum to me
yeah I think I'm getting car oil you
know like when when you when you're
trying to not blow chunks when you're
drunk and you're just trying to make the
straightest face possible that's what
it's like when you're like
oh my God speaking of [ __ ] faces James
Cameron revealed that Avatar 3 will
include the ash people a nation of fire
and a v these will apparently be a
darker take on the navi people Cameron
went on to say in the early films there
are very negative human examples a very
positive Navi examples in Avatar 3 will
do the reserve good the reverse I said
the reserve we'll do the reverse some
scenes of Avatar 3 have already been
shot damn he's getting started I like
that he's doing it you think he's doing
on all sides he's like
it's all shot
that's insane because I think they had
so much if I understood they had so much
time they were updating some technology
and then they were like well let's just
bang out a lot of it because aren't they
supposed to come out every year now John
or is every two years they were just
doing the kids scenes just the kids
scenes oh
John John coming in here
she was like well well my boss is
represent Worthington so I would know
and I was like well I've been reporting
this story for the last two months it
turns out they've shot three
they've got parts of four because
there's gonna be a big time Jump
obviously because they need some like
the flashbacks they showed these movies
in 2016. right
um so they shot three and four and they
shut some of five of
no they shot two and three they shot
some of four and then there's a time
that's insane Who Who Are You
excuse me
I do like this idea of the like get them
off
as you would say the more evil I mean
it's it's kind of a nuanced thing right
it gets into the idea of culture and
whatever's right and wrong on this
planet I don't know I'm not going to put
my I haven't seen the movie based uh
senses on them but like yeah that might
be interesting like yeah maybe there is
a tribe of Navi out there that's like no
we hate all of you we don't like the
planet John's story checks out because
when we were at d23 those kids came out
on stage and they were full-grown adults
they were like we loved our time on
Amazon
they grow up fast I mean the girl that
played curious she's she's a
six-year-old woman I hear
uh The Last of Us show runner Craig
Mason told The Hollywood Reporter his
direction for a season two of the show
would be a direct adaptation of The Last
of Us Part Two some fans have speculated
that a second season might cover the
time between the two games Amazon says
he considers that filler oh sorry you
guys both picked up your mugs at the
same time and it freaked me out
that would be considered filler and it's
not something he is interested in HBO
has yet to green light a further season
of the series yeah yeah you gotta wait
till the first one comes out and the
hype about it they love to do the like
biggest Premiere ever we've grown yeah
the second season right we did the house
of dragons they were like didn't they
greenlink I thought these dragons were
right before oh maybe once before sure I
don't know sure it could be because that
that is also an indication in this world
now where we're like I got invested in
this show and then they canceled it
right like if you know going in oh the
show already is gonna get a second
season I'll definitely watch first
season that's true but that's kind of
surprising to me because I would have
thought they would stretch out game one
time yeah because once they get past
game two I guess they can do whatever
they want I don't know you referred to
it as filler right and he was like I'm
not interested in doing something like
that Damien filler for the first season
he didn't want it to do it I think he
means like for the second season to be
stuff that wasn't it that takes place in
between the games he considers that
filler even though a lot of the first
game is a lot of jumps like you're
you're jumping through you know time
passes as they're traveling from City to
City yeah so I it'll be interesting to
see how they do it especially if they're
gonna jump up the ages of the actors at
all I don't I don't know how you do that
with I mean the time between when they
film things and actors age and a couple
years go by especially when you're
younger you're maturing faster and it's
more noticeable I don't know I guess
they have a plan Jesus Christ
best of luck today yeah we will see when
it all comes out I'm very excited for
this show though I'm very very high new
zombie show yeah yeah love it they're
not zombies they're infected pardon me I
don't know no I guess they got spores up
in there they got spores Sports up in
those pores a recent report by puck
reveals that Fantastic Four has yet to
be cast while fans have been hoping for
a possible Fantastic Four Cameo on
Ant-Man quantumania the likelihood of
this seems close to zero there's also
been those people online that are like
um they're like this is a rumor that's
really big and they have uh what's his
name from Hamilton that played Jefferson
uh
uh Ben Grimm and I was like
okay I will say it here and I will say
it again if they take that black man and
make him Ben Graham I'm gonna be very
upset I'm tired of Disney changing black
people to be like weird
yeah uh well I mean I think Multiverse
events showed us that we could still
have a fantastic four Cameo and it'd
just be like this is a very don't do
that don't do that yeah and I think so
many I think they've listened to the
fans that were I loved it because I love
I was like I fantastic John Krasinski to
play
um play him so so I was very excited but
I know a lot of fans were like do not
make him are Fantastic Four and do not
show us another it's okay I mean we know
now too and Eric I brought this up in
the video this week kind of talking
about like the Bulge or the brave stuff
we've now discovered from three things
that like uh Elizabeth all said and John
Krasinski were like never in the same
room they did never interacted with each
other because she did like an interview
with Vanity Fair where she's like I've
never met this man and they're like
you're in the same movie
happens all the time with this green
screen stuff and so like who knows who
they'll pop into Ant-Man uh I'm not
surprised to hear too that they haven't
Cassie yet the movie's still and so and
it's so far
it's out of this it's out of this world
Ruby baby it's groovy as hell it's so
far out and it's also like
we've been waiting for the Fantastic
Four you want to make sure you are like
actually like looking into the actors
and being like these are the people I
want to play take your time with it
don't freaking do it immediately yeah
take your time take your time yes relax
we want the movie to be fantastic oh
speaking of people that make me upset
not this person just Erica Oh I thought
you meant like your aunt made you upset
I love my aunts I have eight
um speaking of ants Michael giaccino in
American pickle will yes
I love American pickles uh it's one of
my favorite films on HBO Go watch it
we'll be making it anymore
you got Jazz Loft
I love it we'll be making this big
screen directing debut and follow up to
werewolf by night with an adaptation of
the 1950s monster movie Them Channel
till deadline there's always a movie in
your mind that never leaves your head
and for me that's them the original
focus is on a group of giant or uh uh
radiated thank you in the New Mexico
desert yeah this guy clearly loves the
old monsters he wants to do all monster
movies and honestly he should just take
all of the universities old movies and
redo them now this movie was kind of
already remade with a little and in some
bit away with a little uh John Goodman
joint called matinee yes which was about
uh kind of the height of these movies in
the 50s and like thinks theaters would
do to bring people in like uh he plays a
theater owner I think he's based on a
real character yeah a real life person
who like he he attached like electric
buzzers to the seats so that like people
would be freaked out when things happen
yeah he said we have to think we're
getting sprayed with water in the face
when you're trying to watch a mission
impossible oh take me to camera four
um I hate you and I spend a lot of money
just to get my face washed and not by
good clean water what is the water they
use in those theaters
uh Place sauce
Warner Bros Discovery CFO Gunner are you
proud no
says the company's restructuring and
write-off of frenzy has come to an end
we took a little bit of time to make
sure that we do it properly for some of
the titles we found new homes elsewhere
that's why this took six or seven months
but I think we've come to Great
Solutions and most importantly we're
done with that chapter screw you Jonah
yeah that's what he says they're saying
they're saying the X has been put down
if you made it through you're safe
you're gonna be okay I think he's lying
yeah because they like the fear they
want you to be scared keep you on your
toes so so they want the surprise so now
people are going to be safe they're
going to be oh I'm safer then boom
you're gone you're gone you're off oh no
I hope I hope that's uncutting stuff we
got a little pull in the chat guys I
think we should report on that okay
what January show are you most excited
for Last of Us coming in at 51 the bad
[ __ ] coming in at 33 flash season nine
technically February at 14 no love for
flag she's not even though Stephen Amell
said he'll be back as Arrow so many
people returning John diggle will be
back other people will be back
I mean that's interesting you might do a
little bad badge stuff here and there
I'm hearing that we're whipping up a
batch of Badness we might do all bad bad
stuff uh thank you to our superchargers
already today Corey can drill a great
Oliver Bucky Barnes ATL Grace Oliver
saying lots of love from Australia no I
ain't never going there how does this
show look upside down good eye mate how
are those spider webs hanging from the
trees how are those giant spiders you
don't need the super chat but you're
from Australia so I just have to assume
you're obsessed with Star Wars because
that is the only thing that has been
consistent with everyone from Australia
I've ever met I love Star Wars
they love their beer and cocaine okay we
love people all over the world okay
a couple Shadow casters and then watch
the attack of the clowns damn Grace is
about to refund I'm so sorry
okay
just until the cocaine dealer wakes up I
apologize for this Bogan and his
behavior
for our main topic of discussion today
we wanted to talk about uh this script
that has come out for black panther uh
wakanda Forever This Is The Script they
submitted for Academy Awards a
consideration for best adapted
screenplay of course right adapted from
the comic books uh and there are some
key details from the script that didn't
make it into the final cut that may give
us a hint to where phase five might be
headed we had a lot of discussion about
this in the office because uh you see
this a lot the scripts they submit for
the Oscars there will often be things or
or dialogue in the script that's not
exactly how it is in the movie or not
there but this is also like we couldn't
determine which version of the script
this year was because there's multiple
drafts then there's usually like a
shooting script and then you're making
changes as you're shooting the movie and
swapping out pages and then you submit a
script for because this isn't
necessarily even the shooting script as
far as we know yeah and I would say just
from like an auditioning standpoint
looking at these like as if sides you
would get for an audition the uh the
exit the X out usually implies they just
don't want you it's information you can
read but it's not pertinent to the scene
these full uh lines through them sorry
you can't really see I'll hold this up
and see if that's possible these lines
through them that implies that it's
deleted from the scene yeah or so or
it's not going to be shocked I wonder if
this is like a little pageantry to make
it look like I think so that could be
they might have judged it up as they say
so so we were in through it and we
wanted to focus on a main part of
dialogue that comes just after Val calls
Ross out for having the Camellia beads
since the Boston attack this is when
they're in the kitchen uh this is kind
of where it was revealed that they were
married at some point quite shocking uh
so we're gonna read this scene for you
we're into a little dramatic reading
okay uh uh Jessica is gonna play Val
Valentina uh
uh Eric's gonna play Everett Ross yeah
um and Tommy's going to be doing doing
the uh the uh the scene the scene
Direction that's right and we do also we
have a cameo for the role
that we managed to bring a heavy hitter
in for uh also fun to note that the
working title of this script was summer
break which we kind of have theorized
that maybe it was a nod to the original
right black panther story which was
going to be t'challa and Tucson uh or
Too Young t'challa t'challa Jr kind of
traveling around uh forced uh they were
like first on a vacation day other than
forced to kind of fight with each other
not against each other alongside each
other anyway let us begin now we take
you
to Washington DC interior kitchen
interior kitchen
I think it's that side there's no
interior
the wakanda doesn't sink our ship I know
what I got a call from Dr Graham during
the attack Vale plays the tape of
Graham's final phone call during the
helicopter attack I don't know it wasn't
the wakanda's
they were blue everyone is dead
I think when we found that vibranium we
accidentally set wakanda on a collision
course with something new and maybe
that's not a bad thing for us Ross is
taking it back
you had that this whole time the whole
time Vale shrugs
you haven't changed and blue people yeah
I think there who killed Queen Ramona
what else are your friends keeping from
you
okay you know what the wakandans are
good people can you imagine what the
United States would be like if we were
the ones the only country with anything
like vibranium I actually dream about it
she extends a set of handcuffs to Ross
please Val it's director defontaine put
these on and then it's thongs
[Music]
uh well done everyone yeah well pretty
shocking a little extra info so this is
like a big thing right the idea that Val
knew from the jump that it was that
there was these other things down there
this other uh uh racing which is kind of
letting things play out under the
assumption that something else was going
on and wakanda was internal conflict
stuff like that so they left this in the
script wasn't in the movie maybe they
shot this scene as it's written in this
script and we'll see like a cut event in
the deleted scenes uh the movie's coming
to digital later this month and we'll be
on uh Disney plus starting February 1st
yeah I don't know what special features
they'll put on uh Disney plus but there
will definitely be deleted scenes and
stuff on the Blu-ray and all the digital
releases and all that stuff uh but there
also have been rumors out there that
either the upcoming Captain America new
world order or the Thunderbolts movie
will center around Val's team finding
adamantium on the island of Tiedeman
which I I love it I hope it becomes
known as the island of Tampa it's going
to become an island it's like
yeah I was talking to Mt about it now
though but I was like 10 years from now
it's gonna grow like it's gonna get
Foliage and then there's gonna be
another animal people are gonna live
there yeah it's gonna create its own
ecosystem yeah I mean that that is a
fascinating thing I was just watching
this thing about volcanoes and they talk
about when they study like lava flows uh
and as the lava hardens they go in and
they see how how long it takes for
microbes to settle on the the like uh uh
cooled lava right because at one point
our planet was covered in lava and then
God put what just kidding uh life
started on the planet at some point life
had to find a way to grow so I just
cooled cooled laughs are you saying that
lava is the enemy of God possibly it's
the only thing that can kill her
he got the camera stop stop uh so yeah I
mean I love that idea that yeah
eventually life will start to grow on
team which will be very fascinating
maybe it becomes the Savage land I don't
know uh but so all of this information
right it definitely paints Val and the
US government in a more Sinister light
uh we know in our real world that we
live in right now the US government has
done some shady things in the past I
will continue to do Shady things in the
future right
uh some of the rumors and events and uh
uh manipulations that led to uh
different conflicts like the Iraq War
the Vietnam War the Bay of Pigs all
those kind of breaking up with One
Direction the breaking of One Direction
the destruction of the Spice Girls
and let's not forget the moon lasers and
the Chemtrails coming from all the
planes flying overhead and of course
reptoids that's right people that are
secretly reptiles that can shape-shift
into humans right back to reptiles again
Liz
[Music]
this episode of the break room's gonna
get that little message down at the
bottom that he's like this is yeah
they're like a gay frog my biggest
question the freaking frogs game my
biggest especially for all of you is
like with this kind of information what
do you think is like bows in game and
all of this I think chaos I think she I
think the New World Order comes from
chaos right you've got to First destroy
then the New World Order can emerge
because if things are stable and
everyone's happy and people aren't you
scared of each other then there's no
room for a new world order to come in
without just murdering everyone so in
order to get people to get on board to
believe a message that's complete in
other BS you have to first fracture the
people not that that would ever happen
in real life and that's a real life
scenario we can play from so I think
yeah having the the telekinil versus the
wakandas that's just the start of
creating uh enemies amongst people who
would really be better off being allies
now what's next you get to the Americans
you meet the Americans already weary of
the wakandans now they make the American
citizens scared little continents have
all that vibrating they're gonna hurt us
the Pelican they'll have vibranium
they're gonna hurt us we've got to
protect ourselves from these people so I
think propaganda baby that's the end
game propaganda so Valentina could take
over I think
oh nice I think that's the speaker ball
Whoever has that was an incredible
achievement yeah you're breaking the
rules
um I think I think
I think uh per me and mt's conversation
yesterday on inside Marvel I think that
she has to be in charge of two things so
people believe everything she's saying
but also just like following her
Direction now that we know that she's
like the head of the CIA in wakanda
Forever she's doing the political scheme
of just being like hey if I am the one
that's in charge of finding out that who
killed Ramona and doing all this then I
am looked at as someone that can
actually get the job done and do all
these things while she's setting up the
Thunderbolts who is a team that people
were taking a Chance on So it's like
what it's like she won't have to
actually get anyone's opinion on the
Thunderbolts if she's already the head
of the CIA in charge of who's killing
people in wakanda I think when she
figures this out and does all this
because she's sneaky again you guys she
is the number one conniving sneaky
person in the MCU she's gonna go far I
think that's how she's going to be able
to be like I'm also making a team on the
side right and you can't really say
anything about it because I successfully
did this and this which is something
Nick Fury did right yeah he made a team
on the side while running shield and
even while making a team on the side
made like another team on the side right
always playing uh that angle up
um well as you bring up Val and you know
her being in a very front-facing
position as the director of the CIA no
longer like head of this weird Shadow
thing that we weren't really sure what
her role is uh or was in uh uh Falcon
and with her Soldier right when she just
kind of approaches Johnny mayonnaise and
is like hey come join this team she
didn't like give a card to say like
here's my position now she's in a
position where she's going to be hauled
in by Congress and investigated she can
be on the news uh she can get
interviewed by the Press right but it is
Val is do you think she's still part of
some sort of like Shield slash Hydra
heaven forbid group or is she just like
in the CIA and this is the CIA being its
normal Shady self I think doing these
shitty things I think end goal is still
just her I think she's like I dream of
us getting this vibranium because I need
this bike should do it for her and not
in the governor well I think her is the
government when I say this I mean I
believe in America no I don't think she
doesn't believe in America I think she
believes in fact okay and she's the
person in charge of America so I think
it's one of those situations where it's
like it's still a woman that's gonna be
like very hungry for just like a title
like to be the head the head person what
do we know from the Bible women are
treacherous you say you've said this
morning what's on this show and that's
what makes me nervous oh my gosh I hope
no one out there clips that out and puts
it on the internet yeah I would hate
that but if you do send it to me I'd
like to listen to myself when I take
baths silly well yeah I think Val is
definitely I listen to myself when I
take a bath no I agree I heard you yeah
okay then why then what was the question
I'm very confused why you do it oh well
my business is my business anyway I love
that if you taught me uh I think Val is
actively trying to be at both times the
leader of the CIA and also running the
superheroes or villains or as Heroes of
the Thunderbolts uh for the sake of kind
of controlled chaos so with the Avengers
movies beforehand basically every
conflict was caused kind of by The
Avengers them fighting each other them
fighting Loki who was Thor's brother so
them kind of created a problem and then
having to fight and rectify it Thanos
you know they kind of activated the
Infinity Stones and brought Thanos
closer to Earth so I think Val is in
some ways trying to recreate all that by
assembling a thunderboss by getting
Johnny mayonnaise a US agent and by
getting you know whoever she can Wrangle
um
to be part of the new thunderballs so
she can have some of the most powerful
people on the planet and control them
and also
start and have some chaos for them to be
fighting so she's always in charge of
everything that's going on so that
people could be like Val we need your
people to save the day and it's like oh
great I'm the leader I do I say what
goes and all that stuff so I think she
knows that powerful people create chaos
and conflict and strife and big city
damage and so she wants to be the one
she's available she's the Puppet Master
this is Chief Palpatine running both
sides of the conflict right yeah this is
like I'm I'm creating the problems and I
have the solution for the problem so
there's always a problem
yeah yeah I love that idea do you do you
guys think that the Thunderbolts is
gonna be a front-facing group or is she
gonna put them on the news like The
Avengers where there's going to be
action figures and stuff or or they
solely Black Ops no one knows about them
they're still teams I think she's still
smart enough to not do that because
Johnny mayonnaise literally he's already
yeah so I think the last thing she's
gonna do is be like I'm going to show
you guys off immediately after you
yelled at everyone at your court trial
after you did all this Elena is a part
of a secret organization that was like
taking the uterus out of women uh I
think she's gonna let them do something
for a save a big situation and then be
like do you guys wonder who that team
was it's my team the Thunderbolts and
they're all reformed like criminals I
mean there are people who have been
involved in some shady stuff in our
government who are still put on news
organizations and things like that like
these stains they go away after a while
and like yeah Johnny Manny's cave
domains facing uh live on the internet
but also um tiamat's in the ocean who
cares anymore right it's a team of
everyone that has there's a green lady
who's a lawyer now like
if they were if it was a team of the if
there was 12 of them always constantly
together you'd be like didn't that guy
killed this person live didn't this
woman like phase in and out of people
didn't this person do that yeah Scarlet
Witch took over a whole town like
you're like that's when you start being
like this is a lot of wrong people in
one area
well one more thing Marvel has hinted
that secret Invasion ties into armor
Wars and New World Order like all these
kind of like government shows are going
to be typing out spies and uh Espionage
and machinations right
and this is very similar to how like the
government used re-rease Tech to find
vibranium uh do you think that's what
they want the adamantium for is it to
make armor using riri's Tech like oh
they're gonna take all these pieces and
kind of put them together like if if
they are going after the if adamantium
does show up do you think they'll just
like give up the the pursuit of
vibranium and just be like we don't need
it anymore we've got adamantium and that
can be our thing America's adamant yeah
I think they'll go after adamantium so
that they have something stronger than
vibranium I think the US in real life
and in Marvel always wants to be the top
dog just in case sure so they'll be like
oh anime seems stronger than vibranium
[ __ ] the vibranium let's go get the
adamance yeah yeah yeah yeah we'll we'll
let them fall apart on their own we
don't need that we don't need it I hope
they're bringing in the adamantium soon
I think the funniest part is like who
are they gonna put it in like what's
gonna happen with the animanium first
computer isolate who are they going to
put it I'll be using that
but I mean I love this idea of them
trying you gotta imagine that they have
all this Stark Tech now that they
they've confiscated uh they've got they
want to make Vex suit that's going to be
armor Awards it's all about right making
these like Tony Stark slash Riri
williams-esque Mech suits because then
you don't even need Super Soldier serum
anymore the main MacGuffin uh in the MCU
ever since the days of Captain America
right it's always been about making that
again but like if you just build suits
you can throw any schlop into a suit you
gotta worry about injecting them with
juice or drone suits yeah yeah and you
could still control the suits right once
you give someone super soldiers to them
then go off and do whatever they want
right but the suit you can still have
control over you don't have to worry
about who's pilot can act as soon
you can't use that excuse more than once
Tommy you squeezed up the right spot in
my belly and I pooped my suit again
well these are the arm rewards we know
you can pee in the suits Tony Stark
prove that can you poop in the suits
probably
is there a Shoe John confirmed you can
poop is there a shoot in the suit that
releases the poop we gotta get the scoop
on this poop shoot Scoop the Poop shoots
the poop shoots the poops scoop scoop on
the shoots on the poop suit well while
we worry about where the poop goes in
the suits are you worried about where
your money's going this year in 2023
well one thing you could do to save a
little bit of money is stop paying
insane amounts of money every month for
your phone bill it's ridiculous stop
doing it uh right now when you switch to
Main Mobile you'll get their unlimited
plan for 50 off what half off mid mobile
lets you order from home and say what
time you don't got to go to a store just
do it from home and they have phone
plans starting at just 15 a month but
you gotta hurry because this deal ends
January 15th The Ides of January get it
done before then right now you can get
one of their best offers of the year as
the year begins okay you buy any three
month plan and you get three months more
free even on their unlimited plan but
again you gotta do that before January
15th all plans come with unlimited talk
and text plus high-speed data delivered
on the nation's largest 5G Network use
your own phone with any mint Mobile plan
and switch easily in minutes with esim
you can keep your number keep your
contacts all that great stuff switch to
Merit mobile and get premium wireless
service starting at just 15 buckaroonies
a month by any three month at mobile
plan and get three months more free by
going to mintmobile.com breakroom that's
mintmobile.com break room cut your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com breakroom hurry I'm
thanking you the offer ends January 15th
Jessica that's crazy 50 off you know
Christmas trees are 50 off the Big Lots
right now no I did not I actually was
there yesterday I bought the biggest
tree they sell in Big Lots yeah I got
there and the guy at the desk was like
holy cow that's a huge tree are you
gonna put that up yourself and I said no
probably in the living room
what's the punchline
I don't think it was a punchline oh yeah
it's just a fun anecdote for one Tommy
that he bought a Christmas tree after
Christmas
put the tree up yourself
in the living room no I'm gonna put it
in the living room instead of up myself
oh okay it took me a lot it's time for
mandatory fun we lied
that's a little mandatory
sorry guys I gotta figure it out James
Gunn basically debunked a whole Variety
article we reported on yesterday via
Twitter
and that's not where the Tweet storm
stopped right we actually have some more
tweets live from James well this was
this was yeah this was the Tweet he put
out this morning we did this whole thing
talking about that variety yeah we
trusted variety he made us look like
fools like fools once again gun has shot
down our dreams oh my God I don't know
what no huh that was saying that they
they're gonna put out like their they
don't he doesn't know about Ezra Miller
he doesn't know anything about that he
stayed away from that one yeah yeah
but they're gonna put out their their
plan it's eight to ten years not three
years they got more than that and it was
like Wonder Woman's like definitely
coming back I like that he's not
answering he's like that's right I've
never heard that name before so so you
know James Gunn has never one to shy
away from uh tweeting out uh some
debunkings and some Revelations even so
uh here's a few more tweets that James
Gunn uh I'll just put out some more
tweets
Henry Cavill will be returning to the
DCU as Batman oh wow wow
and it's an origin story that's great oh
my gosh we need those it will be an
origin story I like that he tweeted
separately instead of just making it a
thread separate tweets separate tweets
wow is that it I think that's it right
uh I think he also said wait he said I
can confirm Avatar 3 is actually a
direct sequel to Scooby-Doo 2. oh my
gosh wow wow that is great that's the
sequel the streets have been needing are
they gonna fly Scooby-Doo in the gang in
one of those ships and burn out a forest
when it lands wait this is crazy he's
actually live tweeting the show right
now what okay this is Harry Potter
reboot in the works with Chris Pratt
playing all the roles in a mocaps what
come on
even Hermione yes especially Hermione
even Peter Peter grew especially even
Dolores Umbridge yes there's about 200
characters you got to stop
Yes
Patel even Sheamus whose name I thought
was C
even Percy weasel
[Music]
that's Dean Thomas oh magnitude pop pop
uh all right now we also know Aquaman 3
has been pushed to December 13th 2029.
oh my gosh devastating let it come out
wait my Apple watch is buzzing again
okay Lex Luthor will be the next villain
in an upcoming DC film people have waist
length curly blonde hair come on
you know what the myth about power is
what is it
now that's directly from Superman versus
Batman the audio editing is so bad you
can't even hear what he's saying all
right now
wait he's tweeting again were there any
more tweets oh my God WB is partnering
with B and G foods to bring an exciting
new limited series to HBO Max the Jolly
Green Lantern giant oh I love that for
them James come on come on Brandon I
feel like this one's specifically
towards you oh let me read it yeah here
read it oh my gosh the third and eighth
episodes of every series on HBO Max have
been removed just episode three and
episode eight please there's only eight
episodes to like House of the Dragon
this is insane I'm sad you guys aren't
getting these alerts wow I'm getting
another one it was my understanding that
Groot was actually a magical tree I sued
Vin Diesel when he claimed he voice
group come on don't mess with it easily
we saw we did The Rock earlier oh my
gosh oh my gosh well I'm getting another
one oh my gosh Rocket's first name is
pocket so he's a Pocket Rocket Raccoon
Pocket Rocket Raccoon or is he pocket
pacoon
wait oh wow this is crazy
Superman is no longer harmed by
kryptonite suck it whoa come on hi James
good you must be stopped it's a big
change that's a big change a lot going
on over here no I'm gonna put it up in
the living room
you're gonna put it up inside you no I
got the you're gonna put it up yourself
no I'm gonna put it up in the living
room in the living room perfect I got
the joke uh you guys you're gonna put it
up yourself
no Thomas you're gonna put it up in the
living room Mr Bechtel let me draw it
for you
sir back told me sir bechtels was my
father I'm known as mud boy continue
thank you guys for tuning in today we
have a little short episode you guys
because we got we went through it so
quickly it was so much fun plus we're
banging out scripts for some amazing
content coming up we do guys don't worry
about it the break will be back tomorrow
Fast and Furious probably an hour and a
half long for all we know but we got
other vids coming out too Jessica you
haven't been on the channel right now
don't you yeah it came out yesterday uh
we did the blood Witcher origin came out
yesterday we got inside Marvel we have
mt's video coming out about uh Loki and
why everything's orange if you guys were
wondering about that because it's
actually a really indefinite piece that
I would have never guessed empty is a
theorist he knows everything and then
you also put out a short a short it
doesn't come out no I think it's out oh
it did just come out yeah a little
shorty yesterday but it's out there you
guys can go look at our shorts that's
great and don't forget next Monday the
break room's gonna go live a little bit
later uh we're gonna hold the break room
until uh the new trailer for Ant-Man and
the WASP quantumanium drops during the
BCS National Championship game on Monday
night uh so don't tune in at 305 sharp
because it won't be here again no yes
and I won't be there we're gonna go live
a little bit later uh right after that
trailer airs we're gonna do a live
reaction right here on the show talk
about it so be sure to join us turn on
put the game on your second screen put
us on the big screen annoy everyone
who's at your house watching there's no
way you guys want to watch it and by
that point Georgia will be winning by 50
yeah yeah you guys can prepare
yourselves for my birthday the next day
Jessica's having a birthday next week
next week is Jessica next week baby
and then and then next weekend and we're
all celebrating in a special tropical
location so if you're going to be in
Hawaii the 13th through the 15th look
for us look for us we'll be at the most
fun Cabana on the whole Beach you'll
hear us you'll hear us as soon as you
get off your flight yep
[Laughter]
be sure to like And subscribe thanks for
tuning in today we'll see you guys
tomorrow
foreign
[Music]